two weeks after young officers ousted
Burkina fussell's transitional president
in the country's second coup in less
than nine months Captain Ibraham Troy
was sworn in as president at a National
Assembly on Friday military religious
and Community leaders gathered to
formalize treorary's appointment
we need a committed patriot who is ready
to fight for the restoration of the
national territory
at the end of September 34 year old Troy
seized power promising to secure the
nation more effectively than his ousted
predecessor Lieutenant Colonel Paul
Henry sundogo damba who himself
overthrew the country's democratically
elected president in January people are
celebrating the appointment of terrori
as president they say because he's
fought on the ground and seen the
suffering of his people that he'll be
able to change the situation but many
here have little patience and say that
if they don't see results quickly he's
going to be ousted just like his
predecessor
Violence by armed groups has racked the
country for years killing thousands and
displacing some 2 million people some
locals who have fought alongside the
military say they are frustrated by the
lack of assistance and want the new
government to give them more weapons
we fight with our bulletproof jackets
and it's hard sometimes we spend seven
days in the bush we don't have enough
ammunition we have two magazines each
when there's a long attack we run out of
ammunition
many locals and Military are pushing
Troy to work more closely with Russia
instead of the country's former
colonizer France which has been fighting
armed groups in the region since 2013.
outside the meeting for the National
Assembly many were seen waving Russian
flags and denouncing France
our message is that if we want a good
collaboration it should be with Russia
France has been here for about 70 years
they are here they have Barracks here
we've never heard that a French soldier
died it's our soldiers who die but for
many it doesn't matter who Burkina
faso's new leaders work with as long as
they restore peace to their war-weekened
country
Sam mednick Al Jazeera wagadugu Burkina
Faso
[Music]